Speaker 1: Listen, this is completely beyond
parody. A former Trump adviser named Larry Kudlow
and a right wing media host named Mark Levin were
bemoaning that Joe Biden never criticizes Vladimir
Putin. And this was within just a couple of days
of Joe Biden saying that Vladimir Putin is a war
criminal now. The story here for me is projection.
We've talked about projection before and with
modern Trump ism. One of the things we always
have to at least suspect is if they accuse the
left of something, we should look really deeply
at whether they are actually doing it themselves.
When they said, Well, the left doesn't Hillary and
the left don't take care of sensitive information.
They can't be trusted. They're using private
email, we should have said, and some of us did.
They're probably doing it right. And indeed, Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump were using private email,
and Donald Trump was eating and flushing
and burning classified documents,
including stuff that was supposed to be kept
as part of the Presidential Records Act,
taking documents to Mar a Lago, etc. So they were
really doing it. We spent six months before the
2020 election with them saying, Oh, the left is
going to commit fraud, as Donald Trump would say.
And it turned out they tried to commit the fraud.
They tried to steal the election. They insisted
that Joe Biden actually stole it. So when they say
X is going on, what we should interpret that as is
you might be the ones doing X and the idea
of, Hey, listen, the election was definitely
rigged. We should know we're the ones who rigged
it. So of course, now the new thing is becoming
why won't Biden criticized Putin, which of
course, in reality, the problem has been
these soft and not so soft Putin apologists
on the right. So in comes Larry Kudlow,
and he says to Mark Levin, Why doesn't Biden
just come out and criticize Vladimir Putin?
It's beyond parody. Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 2: Let me ask you some just about Putin.
Crazy Putin, who is a criminal. He's an
international war criminal. But why is
it Marc? You and I both worked in the Reagan
administration. I never hear Biden attack Putin.
Speaker 1: Not so. Kudlow literally says
he's a war criminal and that Biden never
attacks Putin. Here is Biden calling Putin
a war criminal for the invasion of Ukraine.
Unidentified: I don't know. He has a word
Speaker 1:
I think he is a war criminal. These guys are
living in a fantasy world. Let's continue,
Speaker 2: Berkeley. I mean, it took a
vulnerability. I wouldn't want to squeeze it
out of them. Yeah, OK, Fine said. He's
a war criminal. Oh, guy, doesn't Biden
ever just come out and criticize Putin and
his system and his war criminality the way
Reagan did to various communist leaders?
Speaker 1: What has Biden been doing?
It's your former boss who first said Putin's
genius and savvy and clever, and he's getting
great land by what he's doing and then had to
walk it back. And even when walking it back,
he continued to make a very, very soft criticism.
Remember during that weird rally, the rally that
Trump did in where was this one? This, I guess
this one was South Carolina. I don't even remember
where he talked about Putin is driven to put
it together. No, he's invading another country,
driven to put it together. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: And for all the talk about violent
conflict in Eastern Europe, and it's a terrible
thing and we're going to help and we're going
to do whatever we can because nobody can look
at the bloodshed much longer. What's happening,
right? A lack of respect for a lot of people.
Speaker 1: It's a lack of respect. Not not
exactly a strong condemnation of Vladimir Putin
Speaker 2: out of things, but it's just a total
lack of respect. And it happens to be a man that
is just driven. He's driven to put it together,
and you look at it and it's just so ridiculous.
Speaker 1: And that's not really a very strong,
strong condemnation of Putin,
right? He's just he's a man who's
driven to put it together. Well, Biden
called him a war criminal. So as usual,
we have to look at their side when they accuse
the left of whatever in this case, it's why won't
Biden more seriously criticize Vladimir Putin?
And of course, the real concern is the Putin
apologists, which included Trump, although I guess
now he's not. Although who knows, he's still using
really strange language like he's driven to
put it together. People like Tucker Carlson,
et cetera, et cetera. You guys know the
list, and as usual, it is merely projection.